and finally new rule the next person
during this pandemic who says we're all
in it together
must work a shift at grubhub
half the country is home in their comfy
clothes ordering takeout and the other
half is out in the cold delivering it so
stop with the in it together
[ __ ]
we're in this together as the new thank
you for your service
just something to say to the people
doing the dirty work so we can feel
better about not doing it ourselves
and even before the pandemic hit america
was already
well into being a gig economy which
sounds kind of hip like you're in a rock
band
except you're not in a rock band you're
delivering hot chicken
and it doesn't cover your rent even side
hustle
sounds kind of cool like you're a
private eye who runs drugs but
really you're an uber driver who also
makes jewelry out of seashells
you can call it remote work but what's
really remote is any chance of getting
health insurance
what are uber and lyft really but
americanized rickshaws
it's not like it's what anyone wants to
do no one ever had a friend throw up in
their back seat and said gosh i hope
someday i can make a career out of this
but in the gig economy everyone is a
freelancer and finding work is the
virtual equivalent of hanging out in the
parking lot at home depot
have a spare room you don't mind
strangers [ __ ] in
rent it on airbnb got some old star trek
stuff from your childhood sell it on
ebay and ship it to some 45 year old
guy's mom's house
even famous people are not above
scrounging for cash on the site cameo
where you can get
d-list celebrities to wish a happy
birthday or get well
soon or tell you a joke and then there's
only fans which last year
swelled from 12 million users to 85
million
and now i'm sure there's some boomers
out there saying bill
only fans what what the hell is that oh
don't worry it's just the side hustle
your daughter's using to pay off her
college debt
no don't worry it's complete it's just a
platform where you can share
recipes or maybe your poetry
yeah you can do that but no one does
it's women showing their vaginas to a
webcam so men can masturbate
i'm sorry i'm being crude what i meant
was only fans is a
social media site or over a million
creators
provide exclusive content to 85 million
subscribers who are masturbating
because apparently that's what our
economy revolves around now
losers in their week old underwear
paying poor desperate web girlfriends
to fake an orgasm while a toddler cries
in the next room
happy valentine's day everyone
according to the website strip chat this
kind of thing has become so routine that
there's actually now
a most popular time of day to take a
break from your busy schedule and rub
one out
and that's between three and four in the
afternoon what i call
fappy hour
jesus forget harriet tubman they ought
to put this guy on the 20.
i'm looking forward to the day when only
fans merges with cameo to become only
cameo
where you can order those has been
celebs to do freaky [ __ ]
that's when we'll know our economy has
hit rock bottom when you can make iron
zerring open a bottle of beer with his
[ __ ]
and he does it because hey anything for
a fan
i'm afraid valentine's day this year
will just be another reminder of how
brutal this lockdown has been for single
people
over half of 18 to 34 year olds don't
have a steady romantic partner
and they're losing precious dating time
women's biological clocks are ticking
guys are balding
in the last 50 years the share of
americans who live alone has doubled
which begs the question if single people
are such a large part of this country
now
why do our political and economic
policies always still revolve around
families just once i'd like to hear a
politician say
i'm congressman harry spooner and i'm
not for working families
i'm for people whose babies ended up in
the reservoir tip
last week mitt romney literally said
this
he said american families are facing
greater financial strain
we have not reformed our family support
system in nearly decades three decades
and our changing economy
has left millions of families behind now
is the time to renew our commitment to
families as they take on the most
important work any of us will ever do
raising our society's children
shut the [ __ ] up
does any politician ever get how
insulting this is to such a large swath
of people
you like kids and family great you do
you
but for millions of others getting a
good night's sleep
not sharing the remote or changing dirty
diapers
never having to have a relationship talk
or listen to a passive aggressive sigh
priceless
you